تواجه متاجر البقالة اليوم
منافسة من أكبر الأسماء في
مجال البيع بالتجزئة عبر الإنترنت ، ولهذا السبب تقوم شركة
تدعى Caper بإجراء عملية تسوق سأعمل عليها
بذكاء ، اعتقدنا أننا سنأخذ
أداة تقليدية يعرف الجميع
كيفية استخدامها وتعبئتها مليئة
بالتكنولوجيا و  المستشعرات في الوقت الحالي ، يمكنك
بشكل أساسي إلقاء سلع ثقيلة
مثل الفواكه والخضروات الخاصة بك ،
وسوف تزن العربة فعليًا
لك ، وستوصيك بعناصر معينة
بناءً على مكان وجودك في
المتجر ، وستساعدك على الخروج حتى يكون لدينا هذه
التسول  خطافات داخل تيارنا
للسماح للعملاء بحمل مشترياتهم من البقالة
أثناء ذهابهم حتى يتمكنوا بعد الانتهاء من
الدفع من الحصول على
حقائبهم والخروج من المتجر ، وهذا النوع من
التكنولوجيا الموجودة
بالفعل في متاجر Amazon go  إنها
نظام معقد من مستشعرات الكاميرات والذكاء الاصطناعي الذي
يتتبع كل منتج يتفاعل معه العميل ،
لذا أردنا التأكد من أنه أثناء
دخول العميل إلى المتجر
يمكنه فقط الحصول على عربتنا والذهاب
يقال إننا نعمل مع
متاجر البقالة في الوقت الحالي ويمكنك تسجيل الدخول
إلى برنامج الولاء الخاص بهم داخل
هذا المتجر حتى يكون لدينا فكرة أفضل عن
من أنت وكيف تشتريها
ولنكملك حقًا بصفتك هذا المستخدم
النهائي في الأساس  الرؤية وما
نبني من أجله هو
أن يدخل العميل إلى المتجر
ويأخذ شيئًا من الرف ،
وعندما يرميه في العربة
، ستحدد جميع المستشعرات والتكنولوجيا والعربة
على الفور ما
يمكن أن يعمل هذا العنصر  بالنسبة لشيء مثل
سلة ، يمكن أن يعمل هذا
لشيء أكبر أصغر حجمًا ، لذا
فهو ديناميكي ويسمح لنا بالذهاب إلى
أسواق مختلفة في الوقت الحالي
، لا تزال عربات الكبر في المرحلة التجريبية ، وأعتقد أن
هذه الوظيفة لن تنتهي قريبًا.
لا أعتقد حقًا أنه يمكنك
أتمتة مساحة الصراف بالكامل ، لذا
فهي حقًا بالنسبة لنا فرصة لتوجيه
هذا التغيير في السوق بالطريقة التي نراها
مناسبة ، فهناك الكثير من الحلول التقنية المختلفة التي
لنأخذ شخصًا ما بعيدًا
عن موقع فعلي ، لذا فإن
ما نبنيه هو تقنية
تجعل التجربة والراحة
التي تراها عبر الإنترنت بلا اتصال
[الموسيقى]